[Música]
y
en este día internacional por el aborto
seguro el aborto está en el centro del
debate en la sociedad colombiana este
domingo colectivos feministas pidieron
frente a la corte constitucional que el
aborto se ha despenalizado totalmente un
acto que sucede después de que el 16 de
septiembre el movimiento causa justa'
formado por 91 organizaciones sociales y
134 activistas interpusiera una demanda
ante la corte constitucional para
eliminar el delito del aborto del código
penal por vulnerar los derechos
fundamentales de las mujeres para este
movimiento el debate no es aborto sí o
aborto no sino aborto seguro o aborto
inseguro este marzo la corte
constitucional se obtuvo de despenalizar
o penalizar totalmente el aborto tras
una denuncia de grupos antiaborto que
pedían una prohibición total los datos
hablan por sí mismos
en colombia el aborto inseguro es la
tercera causa de mortalidad materna en
2016 70 mujeres perdieron la vida pero
es que el aborto también supone un
motivo de criminalización entre 2005 y
2017 2 mil 290 mujeres fueron
judicializadas por abortar de las cuales
cuentas dos eran menores en 2006 y
ratificada en 2018
constitucional despenalizó el aborto con
tres causales cuando existe peligro para
la salud física o mental de la mujer por
malformación grave del feto o en caso de
violación una sentencia que en ese
momento fue calificada de histórica
[Música]
en el marco del día por el derecho al
aborto en mexico las movilizaciones
comenzaron desde la víspera pues este
domingo un grupo de feministas del
denominado bloque negro partió en marcha
desde la comisión nacional de los
derechos humanos para exigir que se
respeta el derecho de la mujer a decidir
sobre su cuerpo esta movilización
antecedió a las de este lunes en varios
estados de la república y por supuesto
aquí en la capital del país para
presionar a los legisladores a que
descongele en las iniciativas en la
materia únicamente la ciudad de méxico y
oaxaca tienen legalizada la interrupción
del embarazo en otros estados se ha
discutido pero se ha desechado además de
acuerdo con el sistema nacional de
seguridad pública con el último fuerte
al mes de agosto en el país hay 434
delitos tipificados como aborto aunque
la mayoría de las mujeres que están en
la cárcel por ello no es precisamente
por el delito de aborto sino que se les
imputa homicidio en grado de parentesco
o algún otro tipo de homicidio
[Música]
el salvador que es de los pocos países
latinoamericanos que criminaliza el
aborto en todos los casos imponiendo
largas penas tanto a mujeres como al
personal médico esta prohibición
absoluta ha resultado en el
encarcelamiento de innumerables mujeres
que han sufrido complicaciones en sus
embarazos y terminan siendo juzgadas por
el delito de homicidio y condenadas
hasta por 40 años de prisión ya en el
2017 la oficina del alto comisionado de
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos solicitó al salvador reformar
sus leyes sobre el aborto y a inicios de
este año un grupo de expertos del mismo
organismo pidió la liberación de las
mujeres que han sido criminalizadas tras
sufrir emergencias obstétricas y que aún
se encuentran encarceladas según la
agrupación ciudadana por la
despenalización del aborto hoy en día en
el país hay 18 mujeres en prisión como
consecuencia de la rígida legislación
penal
[Música]